i still hate intros have a deadly sins
wrath of the gods part 2 ye episode 13.
melioda stabs and appears to defeat
escanor but he's still trapped in
merlin's perfect q power
unfortunately for meliotis it's nearing
noon and the sun starts to come out
empowering eskenore even more and
allowing him to continue fighting even
after the boost in his power eskenor
still can't stand up against meliotis
because his power level is sitting at
114
000 while meliotis is far ahead at 142
000.
we learned that eskinor's power
increases moment by moment when the sun
comes out and reaches its peak at
exactly noon
for exactly one minute he becomes the
manifestation of invincibility known as
the one
his overwhelming power allows him to
defeat meliotis with one strike knocking
him unconscious
escanor appeared to be fine but he was
really severely wounded without him to
keep meliotis in check merlin wants to
keep meliotis inside a perfect cube so
he can't hurt anybody once he's healed
elizabeth requests that she is locked
inside with him which merlin agrees to
after some convincing well they're stuck
in the cube the others will proceed on
their mission to liberate camelot we see
orlandi who had finally found arthur and
is taken to their hideout there are a
bunch of people inside that arthur is
sheltering from the
demons and we get an introduction of a
mysterious cat with arthur named kath
this isn't the only new face as a
foreign swordsman appears named nanashi
who has been teaching arthur to fight
arthur has devised a plan to take back
camelot from the demons by himself
using the holy sword excalibur we then
see that zeldry's is contacted by the
demon king
during their conversation we learned
that meliotis and zeldries are both the
sons of the demon king
now that meliotis has reverted to his
old self the demon king wants him to
take up his rightful place as his
successor
episode 14. zeldrace is obviously not
too happy about the decision and we also
learned that elizabeth is the daughter
of this supreme deity
he is given the task to go and find
meliotis and bring him back
he needs some help but when he tries to
assemble the ten commandments none of
the surviving members respond to the
summoning we get our first look at
monspee and derriere who were last seen
attacking meliotis last season where he
defeated them with his full counter he
could have easily killed them because
they only had one heart left after their
injury transformations
they're not really interested in
fighting anymore so they're living quiet
lives together jewel and gloccinia
finally respond to zeldras but just to
tell him that they're not taking orders
from him anymore
they're removed from the 10 commandments
and zeldries decides that he's just
gonna fight alone to show that he is
deserving of becoming the demon king and
not meliotis he then gets offered some
help from two new faces in pacifier
fiend chandler and napping reaper q zack
these are the former masters to zeldries
and meliotis
chandler is kind of obsessed with his
former pupil meliotis so he rushes ahead
of the others to capture him
shortly after he's gone esther rosa
regains consciousness but is waiting to
fight until he is fully healed back
over the gang where suddenly the sun is
completely blocked out and they are
surrounded by darkness
chandler appears inside the boar's hat
and uses absolute cancel to destroy the
perfect cube that meliotis was in
merlin tries to attack him but he uses
meliotis's full counter move to negate
it she
is hit by her own spell turning her into
a child and then he recognizes her as
the daughter of belly halloween
after supportless monologuing chandler
then shrinks the end with his powers and
launches attacks from the sky
two retaliate king and gother use a
combined technique called celestial
arrow in the last scene
episode 15. in order to circumvent the
full counter gothar creates an illusion
baiting him to use it early
the real celestial arrow is then
unleashed and hits chandler sending him
flying
chandler retaliates with allusions of
his own and injures king with his full
counter he also casts absolute
order on gother which will activate if
gother attacks him
banan king and diane all fight against
chandler since gother can't fight until
the mark on chandler's hand is removed
hawke is able to close the distance
during the lull in the fight and lick
the mark off bring up gother to attack
as normal with the help of elizabeth
healing and go through joining the fight
everybody is able to defeat chandler
after the fight gother suddenly falls
unconscious because the mark on
chandler's hand wasn't completely
removed chandler gets a second win
and has his final boss transformation in
the last scene
episode 16. they can't fight chandler
now that he's powered up so king
prepares to sacrifice himself to buy
everybody else some time
this cues the answers of droll and
gloccinia who show up to help with the
fight king and the end still
try to help out but they're too weak to
fight so gloccinia forces them back to
the boris hat before they get injured
in their fight against chandler both
gloccinia and droll
are killed passing on their legacies to
king and diane
everyone is still weak and trying to
regroup after they're running with
chandler when again chandler closes in
on them blocking out the sun
they all rush to get to meliotis who
they find had just regained
consciousness
still being in his old persona he
informs everybody that he plans to go
with chandler to meet with zeldrys
once he's done that he plans on becoming
the new demon king
in order to use his power to save
elizabeth while hawk is trying to snap
him out of it meliotis says that hawk
has been being used by the demon king to
spy on them he prepares to leave with
chandler but before he goes he
officially disbands the seven deadly
sins
episode 17. after reflecting on
meliotis's comment to hawk
merlin discovers that hawk is somehow
connected to purgatory where the demon
king resides
esterosa is still recovering and sees a
vision of elizabeth coming to visit him
he frantically wakes up and then is
greeted by a new demon by the name of
peronia who has been looking after him
the gang speculates that since hawk is
acting as a corridor between the real
world and purgatory maybe they can use
hawk to enter purgatory if they can do
that then they can go and find meliotis
emotions that the demon king has
stripped away from him
merlin explains that one person has ever
entered purgatory and returned alive
her father who had served as the
reigning chief of belly halloween had
discovered a door to purgatory
after only one minute inside he had
returned but was a complete shell of his
former self
the stories he told talked about a
hellish landscape and hostile
environment where time is distorted
every minute that passes in the real
world is equivalent to one year passing
in purgatory
band volunteered to go into purgatory
and retrieve the emotions by himself
since he is immortal
over to the demon brothers reunion where
all of them argue over who
should be the next demon king
the fighting suddenly stops when
meliotis whispers something into
zeldriese's ear and he suddenly becomes
cooperative
saying that he's going to help meliodus
meliotis still doesn't have enough power
to face the demon king though the demon
king had so much power that he
distributed half of it amongst the ten
commandments
miliotis plans to take control of all of
the power that was
lent out in order to be on the same
level as the demon king
vildrace already has three taken from
gother droll
and gloccinia miliotis had also taken
grey road's commandment before so
zeldry sent esterosa leave to find and
retrieve the remaining commandments
while meliotis stays behind
with elizabeth in order to take a
commandment from the target they must
agree to give it up
or be incapable of combat meanwhile
merlin uses hawk to transport ban
into purgatory elizabeth knows that if
meliotis takes on the demon king's role
he will likely not be able to stay in
this world
she begs him not to go through with it
because she doesn't want to live without
him he says that he has and always will
love her but now that his emotions are
gone he can't feel that love
without his emotions he is solely
focused on fulfilling her request to
lift the curse no matter what
she declares if that's his position then
she's going to rejoin the sins and stop
him
after slapping him through a wall she
makes a run for it in search of the sins
in the last scene
episode 18. still dress finds the sins
and merlin greets him to negotiate since
he is after molluscula's commandment
when she takes on her child forms elders
recognizes her also as the one who is
blessed by both the demon king and
supreme deity the two of them leave to
carry out the negotiations in private
and then we jump back a couple of days
prior the holy nights
dreyfus and hendrickson travel with
princess margaret in search of gill
thunder
if you remember there was a quick scene
where gil thunder had been forcefully
teleported away by vivian during their
standoff against gray road because she
was in love with him
margaret wanders up and disappeared so
they have to go look for her they find
her at a druid's altar where a voice
offers to return
gil thunder to her but at a cost she
ignores the warnings from the knights
and says that she will pay any price to
get him back
the voice was the [ __ ] archangel
ledociel and he takes control of her
body to fulfill his mission of
destroying the demon clan he isn't the
only archangel that has returned as
tariel and soriel had
also found bodies of their own to
inhabit we see gill thunder being held
captive by
vivian but ledelciel had tracked them
down and kills vivian
he sets margaret's lover free upholding
his end of the deal
in return he's going to continue using
margaret's body until his overall goal
is accomplished
back on over to zeldry sam merlin where
we learned that merlin is from belly
halloween which is the capital of the
wizards
billy halloween was neutral in the holy
war and eventually merlin was born
she was a miraculous genius who had the
power infinity
both the demon king and the supreme
deity wished to have her join them so
she said that she would join the side
that gave her a better gift the demon
king offered
all knowledge of the demon realm secret
arts and protection from the goddess
race's brainwashing spells
on the other hand the supreme deity gave
her protection that would negate all
dark curses
even the ones from the ten commandments
we see that the sins are listening in on
this conversation as well through
merlin's magic
merlin went on to accept both of the
gifts but then refused to join either
side
furious that she didn't keep her word
the demon king and supreme deity worked
together to destroy belly halloween but
anyways during the negotiations merlin
agrees to give him
an escalant in exchange for him
releasing the people that are enslaved
by the commandment of piety
he agrees to this and we see that all
the people in camelot that were being
held in trance-like states and ruled
over by the demons are finally released
before deactivating her perfect cube and
giving him a lescola zeldrich takes a
massive long-range shot from ledociel
yep so 19. merlin retreats back to the
boris hat and zeldrice returns fire at
ledocial and the knights
chandler finds out that elizabeth had
made a run for it so he sent some of his
fat after her to kill her the sins get
to camelot since deldries is likely to
order the demons to kill the residents
because merlin had broke off the deal
with him the residents are teleported
away to leonis and diane comes across
elizabeth chandler's fat gives her an
unfortunate haircut but deen saves her
life and they all escape
after camelot was saved everybody
returns to leonis where gill thunder and
ledocial show up with the other
archangels
the archangels are there to continue the
holy war so they request the aid of the
holy knights and the sins
because they don't have the power to
stop meliotis on their own stigma and
the seven deadly sins form an alliance
against him during a celebration
of the new alliance the politics of the
azure sky members approach the
archangels to tell them that they don't
trust them
ludociel then uses his power to send
them into euphoria and
instantly wins them over ensuring that
they're gonna stay in line the
archangels also say that the fourth
archangel mael was killed by
ester rosa episode 20. arthur is trying
to get to the castle and retrieve
excalibur but perronia is preventing him
using her illusions
meanwhile merlit is repairing gother and
while doing so he requests a favor from
her but we don't hear what it is
eskenore is revealed to be crushing on
merlin which is a little bit scary
because her true form is a child
while walking with hawk ludocio picks up
on eskenor's power and approaches them
once ludocio learns about his power he
attacks
eskenore demanding that he explain how
he got his power
turns out his power is like the
commandment's power but it's known as a
grace that was granted by the supreme
deity to myel the fourth archangel
the other archangels are all in
possession of graces also
ludocl's grace is called flash tarmiels
is ocean
and sorry else is tornado while eskenor
is in possession of the fourth grace
sunshine he goes on to explain that his
brother mael was murdered by one of the
commandments three thousand years ago
and
lost the grace ludociel plans to force
eskenore to relinquish the grace to him
but eskinel refuses saying that he was
born with the grace and it's his power
now this forces him to stand down for
now and we hop back over to arthur where
kath had located perronia and ends up
eating her to break the illusion
we see that esther rosa had located the
petrified gallon who apparently is still
alive
he then retrieves the commandment by
smashing and killing gallon
arthur manages to make it inside the
castle but immediately runs into
zeldry's
cath buys him some time to get to
excalibur but gets injured while doing
so
meliota shows up and explains the
situation about how he left the sins
behind
arthur is appalled at his betrayal so he
draws excalibur to fight them the sword
gives arthur the ability to stand up to
zeldries and miliotis as well as their
old masters
we then learn the history of excalibur
from merlin many powerful warriors
wielded the sword across
thousands of years and the sword was
infused with all of their souls this
allows arthur to emulate the moves of
all of the strongest heroes that had
possession of the sword before him
arthur has been acknowledged by all of
the previous generations infused with
the sword as the king of kings
episode 21. turns out it looks stylish
but arthur was really doing zero damage
to the demons kath explains that he
can't do anything until his powers
awaken
arthur hasn't trained his body enough to
handle the strain that the sword puts
him under and he starts to fall apart
merlin is forced to swoop in and
teleport him away before he is killed by
cusack
although they managed to escape cusack
had cast a spell on arthur which allows
him to control arthur's body
he uses this to force arthur to stab and
kill himself with excalibur
with arthur dead everybody else has to
refocus on the upcoming battle
everybody is split into three different
forces the first force is defending
leonis the second force will push
through to camelot while dealing with
any demons along the way
and the third is the assault force that
will hit camelot directly
we then see zeldras give up his
commandment to meliotis who absorbs the
five commandments that they have
possession of
and while that's going on everybody else
moves out to implement their plan
the second force comes across an army of
demons waiting to greet them reigniting
the holy war
episode 22 we see that leonis has fallen
under attack
also meaning that this is the opening
for merlin and the assault force to make
their move
we get a look at the village where
monsby and derriere have been staying
which is evacuating because of all the
fighting nearby
derriere and monsby are both happy with
their quiet life so they plan to return
their commandments to zeldry's
before they can though esther rosa had
found where they were hiding and kills
the woman that was giving them a place
to
stay during the fighting knights and the
pilates of the azure sky think that
they're more powerful now because they
had been blessed by ledocial
elizabeth steps in to tell them that
really the power he used just induces
euphoria and that she was actually the
one healing them throughout the fight
back to esto rosa who fights with
derriere and montsby where he reveals
that he's planning on taking all of the
commandments for himself he
starts choking out monspeed but he
wasn't aware of the fact that monsby can
trade places with things
he uses this to turn the tables on ester
roses so now he's the one choking him
out it appears that esterosa loses
consciousness but as soon as derriere
lets her guard down he grabs her as
esterosa prepares to land a fatal blow
on her monspeed sacrifices himself by
switching places with her he then uses
his powers to knock her away and causes
a massive explosion to secure her escape
episode 23 derriere comes across all of
the knights in the second force
meanwhile that leonis greymore is nearly
killed by a grey demon and dreyfus
rushes to his aid thinking that he might
die dreyfus suddenly grows into a giant
thanks to fraudrin lending him his
powers
anyways derriere had lost her will to
fight and wasn't sure where to go
so when she came across elizabeth's
power she went looking for
before they can really say anything
esther rosa shows up and uses a vortex
to cut the two off from the others he
plans to kill derriere and take her
commandment so elizabeth knocks him away
where he runs into tarmiel and sariel
they both gang up on esther rosa
combining their graces to attack him
with endless divine punishment
presumably killing him in the process
however when they return to the others
esther rosa shows up behind them but now
his power has increased to 88
000. whenever they try and kill him he
just keeps on laughing and getting
stronger
it's revealed that he had taken control
of gallon's commandment and he absorbs
monk's beats commandment as well
this makes him even more powerful and he
takes on a tire similar to what meliotis
was wearing
episode 24. we get a flashback to when
esther rosa was younger and had known
elizabeth he wanted the war to stop and
was in love with her
in the end he realized that all he
wanted to do was become meliotis
back to the present where meliotis is
still slowly absorbing the commandments
even though he's more powerful esther
rosa seems to think that he's meliotis
and is kind of going [ __ ] crazy
elizabeth comes to the conclusion that
his body is rejecting the three
commandments that he had absorbed nobody
can match his power and everybody is
being injured trying to get to elizabeth
she casts her healing magic on everybody
and in order to protect them she tells
esther rosa that she'll do whatever he
wants
satisfied with that he then flies off
with elizabeth leaving the others behind
after the fight we see that sariel's
vessel had grown into a hot woman
this is because the bodies they inhabit
decay through the continued use of their
graces and eventually disintegrate
because of this the archangels leave
their bodies and take on their original
forms we also see derriere had
volunteered to join them in their fight
against meliotis and the others
king the archangels and derriere all go
ahead to look for elizabeth since they
can fly while the others continue
south towards camelot when the third
force arrives at camelot they find that
meliotis had caused a massive zone of
darkness
after being fused with the commandments
ludocl uses his sanctuary power to get
them inside but tells him that the only
way out
is killing meliotis merlin corrects him
saying that the other possibility is to
revert meliotis back to the way he was
this gives our first look at ban inside
of purgatory who is still making his way
to get meliotis emotions back
in the last couple of scenes we see all
of the characters heading towards their
objectives and melioda is still asleep
in his cocoon
after the credits we see normal meliotis
who was inside purgatory and determined
to get back to elizabeth
i'm gonna be doing the future seasons
and you can find that in the left side
whenever i'm finished with that or you
can check out all the seven deadly sins
recaps in the playlist on the right side
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros is outros